we're pleased to have calling into the
show none other than the franchise
leader in passing yards completions and
touchdowns in his tenth season in the
National Football League Matthew
Stafford
how are you Matthew I'm doing what does
a bye week
mean for you walk me through it it means
um just a little bit of a recharge you
know obviously got a little bit of week
work done early in the week Monday
Tuesday Wednesday with the guys and then
a little bit of time off after that and
a chance to relax can I get the body in
the mind feeling a little bit better and
get ready to uh you know go for another
11 games here okay so what does that
mean you're gonna make a shin you're
gonna do the the Romo Cabo trip or what
I do uh you know a little bit of time
with uh with my girls and then my wife's
I'll probably scoot away for a couple
days nice I grab some Sun somewhere and
then you know maybe come back later on
the weekend and get ready to go for next
week how old are your girls now I have
two twin daughters that are 18 months
old and then we've got an eight year old
daughter at the house so it's busy times
oh my god so so okay let me hear let me
think of this so while you're preparing
for say the Packers are you sleeping the
night through here I mean what I mean
what are you got going on yeah sleepers
my wife to camp we got some help around
it's incredible so we need it because I
got to get my sleep and early everybody
does so it's been good we've got a
little little process going get thing
going and Trust the process Matthew you
guys you've got to trust that process
and and the process it's just been it's
it's fascinating watch the way the Lions
season has been playing out so much of a
conversation about former Belichick
assistants in their ability to succeed
outside of the Belichick womb I guess to
use I guess some of the baby phrases
here what does Matt Patricia brought to
the equation that you've seen that is a
in a way a little bit of a difference
yeah it's been good you know obviously
I've played for three head coaches now
and and each one of them different in
their own right and
you know each one of them coming from
different systems and different
backgrounds and and uh you know they're
obviously just different people with
their personalities rub off on the theme
a certain way and Patricia is a fiery
guy you know he's definitely you know
working a start and I think it's you
know benefiting us we're playing some
good football times we got to do it more
consistently but when we're playing at a
high level it's been successful for now
the work in is hard comment or statement
that you just said right there that is
what a lot of folks are pointing to
certainly after the week one loss
against the Jets on Monday Night
Football being worked hard what does
that mean you know I come in every
single day and get better and and put it
on a work in and it's been good for us
it really has you know this is a tough
mentally and physically a tough football
team and I think it shows up in games
and hopefully shows up throughout the
season and how important was it for you
that Jim Bob cooter was kept in place
you know I've had a bit of success here
over the last couple years I think he's
a really smart guys got a really good
feel for our players our locker room and
really good in game feel on make an
adjustment so you know obviously wasn't
up to me but I was happy to see him stay
and happy for us to you know just
continue building what we got going now
what did it feel like to have a hundred
yard rusher during a game it was great
it was great we've done a nice job on
the ball you know I think obviously
carry on had the one game but we've done
a nice job we've been handing it off
we've been good in yards and and some
explosive runs as well so it's been a
nice you know a nice step in the right
direction for us so far this year gotta
continue to improve and get better no
problem it's an Auburn guy though right
for you no no we're ok ok
good problem guys from Florida guys you
know on this subject I might as well
just veer off the beaten path a little
bit with you Matthew Stafford
how come and I know this does come from
a Michigan guy ok and you there being
the state of Michigan know that the
Wolverines Michigan state every year
ohio state every year penn state every
year
how come Georgia and Alabama
don't play every year what gives in that
department Matthew you know how ya be
the Commissioner to the SEC one day and
I'll let you know but it's an SEC East
as you see with I think I think we I
would love to see him play every year to
really good football teams especially
nowadays you know both programs really
on a roll and it'd be a great one to see
don't you think George you would want a
piece of Alabama right now yeah I mean
you know at some points in the SEC
Championship later on down the road yeah
I know that game to me it's just what a
waste of time at that game all they're
gonna do is maybe beat one of what one
of each other up and allow maybe Notre
Dame to get in okay you just focused on
the professional football so what you're
saying right okay all right very good
and you know one one one storyline that
that never really materialized and it's
a pretty amazing from a few years ago is
that Calvin Johnson's retirement would
leave you without someone to throw to
and lo and behold you have a ton of
weapons at your disposal was there any
sort of I guess a grieving or any sort
of any sort of process that you had to
go through because it seemed like you it
was seamless from you to one or the
other I think there was definitely a you
know a mental side of the game to change
you know really more so with what
defenses were going to do to us I first
so long I saw so many unique coverages
and covered over to Calvin and all sorts
of stuff that you know that evened out a
little bit more only got Mauro this
obviously golden Kenney seven or eight
years force
tight ends sprinkled in running back so
I think we supposed to defense out with
more weapons nowadays than maybe we did
back in the Calvin era but yeah it was
just just when I had to make and I
seemed had to make and I think we did a
nice job like that kid Galah days a
beast I mean everything you throw it and
he catches Matthew it's pretty doing a
nice job yeah no question you know how
to good I think they did rookie year and
really came in this offseason ready to
work hard and and you know ready to take
that next step I think he's doing a nice
job okay now his Golden Tate really
upset that Pat
mahomes is being nicknamed Showtime
Matthew deep down do you think he's
really upset about that I had no idea
that was the thing Brett so he's not
talking about the locker room maybe that
was me at least but so maybe maybe a
little overblown I'm not sure okay
overblown because okay this one makes
sure now in terms of a nickname what is
your nickname do you have one no
everybody just calls me staff staff or
nine there's nothing nothing fancy about
me do you want one
rather not can go in too many directions
you know well I've got one for you what
do you got okay now I'm getting full
disclosure giving you full disclosure
Matthew yeah I tried the Sun I places
full disclosure for you hold on before I
get to it I got to give full disclosure
before I give it to you this nickname I
try to give to your buddy Matt Ryan okay
no no no no that's accuse me hold on it
was because I thought Maddie ice was
ridiculous I was trying to help I was
trying to help him out okay okay so he
has been polite about it I don't think
he's really embraced it to be very
honest with you so now it's yours if
you're so choose the natural - nice
sounds good it sounds good and it's been
seven years that he still hasn't really
adopted it yeah be honest should I move
on are you telling me to move on to the
next Matt I know you said you were gonna
go someplace warm with your wife I don't
know if Milwaukee serves as that I know
Kershaw is coming to town big big game
on coming up are you gonna maybe catch
probably gonna cruise over Milwaukee but
I'll be pulling for him from afar for
sure I uh you know I've been watching
and he had a great one the other night
and I actually you know happy those guys
so it should be fun he did and one last
thing for you in all seriousness would
you think a breeze you know age 39
hitting that mark knowing obviously what
it takes to be a 9 in this league and
and also what it takes to just mentally
prepare and physically get through
things
week after week the fact that he's
reached that milestone Matthews
extremely healthy for him he's done that
at a high level for such a long time and
you know he's a fun to watch man and he
deserves all of it happy for him and
happy for his family it was pretty cool
do you have an age in mind for yourself
about when you I don't you know I just
want to keep playing as I'm healthy I'll
keep playing and and if I'm not or
something else changes along the road
we'll see but I really enjoy playing
those both doing what I do so I'm not
sitting beside myself you shouldn't you
shouldn't and I think you're gonna play
to a ripe old age you know why because
you have natural ability great shot man
enjoy your bye week we'll chat down the
road it's Matthew Stafford the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience